[Music]
emmanuel thanks for coming down no
worries did you get started in property
so i first got started um when i was
working at lloyd's banking group um i
was working there um they had this
i would call it a scam but basically i
was working there i did what you called
the degree apprenticeship um so similar
to many people a lot of people don't
know the government will actually pay
for you to go to university and also pay
your salary at the same time with that
money that i saved up i was able um to
put deposit down on a house what made
you want to buy a house so bad most
people just spent that on lots of other
things i understand just renting i just
thought um i was losing a lot of money
that way um i wanted to build sort of
wealth generational wealth and how old
were you like 20 i was 21. oh no i was
20 when i first my property because at
young age yeah very young so you must be
quite a smart person to be working at
lloyd's bank at uni what were you
studying i was studying computer science
okay so no one gave you like a handout
for that first time no no no no no i was
all myself it was all hard work um prior
to that i was working all my life um i
had different jobs
different hard-working jobs because the
average age to get a house is like in
their 30s now yeah so you buying a house
at 20. yeah yeah that's kind of i think
it was just leveraging what i knew at
the time
and sort of not having that student left
at the same time i'm earning a decent
salary from a young age and instead of
spending all that money sort of
investing in and thinking let me just
buy my first house basically so and
you've gone on to obviously build a nice
portfolio that's correct and you've done
ridiculously well and you're now what 20
you just turned 24. yeah i just turned
24 yeah that's great okay so that first
house then
what happened what happened next so i
bought that first house uh my boy it was
fine i was living in it it was up in
manchester it was great um i want to
sort of
get a lot more properties but the
barriers or certain things that are
stopping me with finances for example so
i just came down to the crash course
because obviously i had sort of plans on
sort of investing in property and i saw
that you advertised sort of no money
down there was getting involved in uh uh
property with no finance available so i
thought let me just come down explore
see what i can actually do it's funny
because that they actually just had
attracted on me and i had to borrow one
of my brother's tops just to make sure i
go look smart presentable but you're a
banker i know i know i didn't plan to
come down to this you know i mean i'll
just oh right yeah yeah i wanted to look
more presentable yeah i just bought now
a tracksuit wouldn't kite i was like
shouting my brother and i still got a
picture to my phone the first time i met
you we took the selfie and then we are
here we are now which is amazing but i
came down um listened to what you said
and then i noticed i had a lot of equity
in my property right now um so i just
thought i could use that sort of money
um sort of scale up rather than paying
these huge down payments on my mortgage
and sort of refinance and then build up
my portfolio that way i make a lot more
money so you learned about the whole the
brr exactly the brr strategy that that's
the only strategy i do now to this day
that's my main focus in terms of
investors so talk to me about what brr
is how's it so uh by me personally i buy
a random property um i do it up renovate
it um i refinance it pull most of if not
all the equity out and then i just rent
it out straight after you're like
recycling cash exactly so people think
you need a lot of money but you're
actually just recycling your money what
happened with your job at lloyd's also
last year around the june so it's
actually going to be a week anniversary
soon i was made redundant from lesbians
why did they make you redundant um would
you not do a good job nah nah i was
doing a great job it was a horse of uh
restructure and then my role didn't
exist anymore so yeah
in beckensfield yeah lloyd's bank are
literally closing down their bank in the
high street yeah okay
they're like taking out banks from high
streets it's not necessary though it's
unfortunate because it means people
aren't going to lose jobs which is sad
and if you haven't got sort of like the
entrepreneurial spirit sort of get up on
it look how many people in 2020 lost
their jobs good like laughton
yeah yeah super smart guy correct
working in a good job paid well lost it
in lockdown yeah and then all these
people then come to my courses yep and
then end up you know it kind of works
out well you've got you can't just sit
on your farms you get i mean you've got
to sort of do something yes
looking back in hindsight are you glad
you lost your job yes because i don't
think i would have the courage to leave
i think i was very comfortable i think
stability was very important for me and
especially for my background my parents
would have
wanted me always to have a job i mean my
brother's got a really good high paid
job so
i was supposed to just follow in that
steps to be an investment bank or have
this high paid job yeah so
god has another plan exactly no i agree
i agree i agree right definitely okay so
you got my redundant in when was that
last year last year 2021
um
you learned about the whole you did some
training with myself yes you went on the
deal selling master class you're now on
our mastermind correct that's correct
whatever which is which is great so what
have you done since like how many houses
do you currently sold i currently have
uh five five houses right now um on our
way to getting the six months and you're
24 yeah i'm 24 correct my god that's
good though bro that's seriously good
and you're making a decent income from
that very very decent income and what i
like about this sort of strategy it's um
completely hands off for myself once i
am going to get there we're going to get
there that's weird so it just gives me
time to like i said i'm on development
mastermind now it just gives me time to
focus more yeah on development time and
at the end of the day i want time
more than money so um if i can just free
up my time or just it's a lot more it's
more important to me having all the
money in the world so
with this it just works perfectly for me
where are your houses so they're all
based up north and northwest for
predominantly manchester burnley
blackburn aquinton that sort of area and
where do you live i live between man i
live in manchester and london between
the boats i grew up in london went to
university in manchester and sort of
built my portfolio based up north in the
northwest the reason i did that because
it was more accessible in terms of
lower uh barriers to entry in terms of
how much finance you need to put in and
because i just knew the area because i
went to university there i started
computer science so i didn't doing
nothing related to my degree which is
unfortunate
nothing related so often that happens
a program yesterday there was about 300
people in the room and i said to
everybody put your hand up if you went
to university yeah and probably i don't
know 60 of the hands went up yeah i said
keep your hand raised
if you're currently in a job
that has nothing to do with your unit
everyone's hand pretty much still was
raised it's crazy and i remember you um
you had to you had to shoot off early at
one of our programs because you you were
getting your graduate yeah graduation so
i had to go out to my graduation for one
of the so the two day event when the
second and fourth unfortunately i had my
graduation well you came back
what's um what did you get what did you
get in uni oh i've got two one i've got
two one yeah i don't know what that
means but i think it's good yeah it's
good yeah so you got the first two one
two three on the third yeah yeah so i
got one below the highest possible so
you're smart
you got made redundant yep you finished
your you knew studies
you bought your first house from a
hustle and savings definitely when i
first got a mortgage it was 0.1 but i
know it has risen a bit a little bit
yeah yeah do you know do you know it's
not been that low for over 400 years i
know i don't know
everything's happened at the right time
yeah it does man god's favor man
so okay so you you learn about this
whole brl recycling you refinance so
that first house that you bought how
much do you pay for it 109 109 000 and
then how much did it go up to it's
bought for 56.56 yeah how much you spend
on it uh i spent about 51 in it as well
okay so in total you're talking about
107. yeah did you play stamp duty or did
you not have to pay it because of that
we had to pay it but we're in the refurb
are in the process of reclaiming that
back cool that's one thing i also
learned as well from the network i've
built is that you can actually get a
stamp shoot you black yeah
right
how long do you have to climb back um i
think it's about we have two there's two
years and five years so it's different
procedures for each time people don't
understand this yeah some of the people
that come to my courses that are already
in property are like damn i can claim
all this background yeah definitely okay
and then what so you see you bought it
for about 57
yeah you spent 51 on it yeah
and then how much what was the revalue
the came back at 150
came up 150 no 150 or 135 i'm not too
sure i could use them so many deals now
yeah yeah
so but the basic essence is you push the
value up exactly and then you refinance
it at the new value pull out the
majority of your funds
from what i remember we only left around
seven grand in the deal yeah yeah around
about seven grand so based on in like
six months or in a year's time that yeah
that would be basically back in
yeah and then you can just keep
recycling your deposit again and again
talk to me about
because i did a video about this
recently it's good to have you on the
channel
about who your tenants are
and
how much rent and profit you're making
okay so basically um i wanted to free up
my time like i mentioned earlier so i
didn't want to sort of put my house in
the private rented market because it
just comes with headaches and i know if
a boiler breaking down or something
could wipe out like a year or a couple
months profit yeah so what i decided to
go is go down the social housing route
which is basically give your property to
housing association they pay you do a
fixed rent for around five to seven
years and it's completely hands-off
basically any problems in the property
they will take care of it and they'll
manage everything and they'll only call
your or your phone if there's any
structural issues with the property so
if the boiler breaks they'll fix it
they'll fix everything if the tenant
breaks their window they'll fix it
they'll fix it yeah i'll fix it and what
happens if
they don't pay you the rent or they have
it they will they have to yes it's all
in the contract
yeah they will have to
even like say for example during the
pandemic they will still pay whereas
some some tenants have rights not so how
much rent are you getting like for these
houses so uh for the
association i go with it it's a bit less
than the sort of the private rented
market but you have to sort of take
consideration that it's completely hands
off and you haven't paid for any sort of
problems in the house so it's a bit less
but it's still a good turnaround so for
for example a 4-bed hmo will get you
around maybe the 1 000 1.2 mark yeah
which isn't too bad if you take or you
ain't gonna pay no bills you haven't got
to pay for nothing breaking down this
that's net profit one two two one what
are the pros and cons of housing
associations versus running it yourself
and running it as a hmo or something um
the pros of hearthstone assertion is
like completely hands-off um you're
gonna get a guaranteed rent um
there's no problems it's quite
straightforward it's one contract um the
cons like i said is the rent is a little
bit reduced but you have to compromise
at the end of the day they're taking all
the stress off you and you're freeing up
your time so for that little bit of
pricing difference i think it is a pro
because it just frees up my time to
whatever i want basically yeah yeah make
this passive income passive yeah exactly
so what have been some of the biggest
challenges building because now you're
full-time property yeah you don't have a
job anymore you're financially free
correct yeah what sort of income are you
making at the moment around three grand
but once all my projects are done it'll
be rough around the five grand a month
yeah and that's passive
yeah and you've built that up from from
nothing
and you're like literally just turned 24
correct that's incredible so what would
you say
have been some of the biggest challenges
were there any times when you wanted to
quit
challenges oh i think it's the whole uh
building phase in terms of getting
builders in getting quotes coming in i
haven't got sort of like a property
background so understanding walking into
property and knowing how much sort of
refurb is going to cost and finding the
black tradesman and the right build team
i think that was sort of my big um
hurdle i had to come across i think but
over time i just got better
understanding how much a damp proof
course would how much a new roof would
cost all these different things i think
you just pick up as time goes on but
that was definitely um one of my biggest
obstacles one starting to be honest you
know have you done any other strategies
and we've literally just done this stuff
just brr the reason why i like the br so
much is because you could do the
standard bad luck but it's just pulling
this equity up it's the reason why i've
been able to get so many with such a
quick time because i don't be leaving 25
equity in houses all the time no of
course not have you sold any deals i've
so yes i have sold some deals as well so
i've done that as well um i went on your
deal selling masterclass um i understood
how to sort of package those and sell it
off to some investors so um i sold a
deal i didn't recently i saw the house
in liverpool um i sold that for two
grand um i called code deal source on
that one so um i split the profits for
the person that was actually um sort of
managing for me because at the same time
um i wanted to sort of store carry on of
what i did on the side and just ensure i
can still do so because when deals come
to me and a lot of estate agents come to
me instead of me sort of saying no i
don't want to buy it yeah yeah it's just
a smart way of sort of producing more
income in fact 100 and we spoke about
this i mean there's a difference between
an active deal source or a passive deal
source so you're a passive deal sorcerer
so you're the kind of guy you want to
build your own portfolio
but if you're looking out for houses for
yourself
you're going to come across some houses
that don't quite work for you so rather
than flush them down the toilet and say
no thanks you may as well sell them
the training was only two thousand yeah
correct correct so one deal and it's
made it back and then you've got that
string to your bow
um so what's next then for you what are
you doing now what's next development
development that's my goal that's where
i want to project myself and i have
signed up to your i went i came to your
one day development crash course and
then i signed on again to the
development deep dive which is a more in
depth to the understanding of
development and i got something i was at
my house yeah correct correct so i got
to
come to your house as well and then
i signed up for because i got so much
value from it um and i knew that just
something i really wanted to do and i
knew if i took if i took action i'd be
able to get results because i've seen
other people do it
within your groups i said let me sign up
to the development uh mastermind and i'm
on that crack now it's amazing i get
amazing support from
the teachers and it's just great overall
basically that's good man i appreciate
you saying that how can you justify
investing thousands and thousands
constantly in yourself because
if people what i said is people can
spend this much go to university and
then end up using their degree if you
really want to do something you
shouldn't let the finances hold you back
especially if you know you're going to
make that money
from maybe one or two deals then it's
just the best investment you can make
and if you don't put the training in
there's a lot of mistakes you can make
you don't understand
a lot more you've rather just going with
the training of the training just helps
you build a network and a group of
people that can support you on your
journey at the same time which i think
is even that's even value for money if
you have someone that can mentor you and
show you that alone is huge value that
people don't understand yeah and just
find these right people and you only
find these people
um when you see that they're doing
things that you want to do so you want
to stand on the street they need to be
in the same areas as you or looking for
the same things as you and you tend to
find them on property courses and your
sort of courses and they tend to be open
to help and women's help which is
something i notice kind of like a
community and family where you can go
together and ask people and even venture
people which is amazing yeah that's
right man so what's um what's been the
biggest takeaway would you say from your
experience of everything you've built
you're 24 you're just buying your sixth
house at the moment
what's been would you say if you if you
were speaking to your
two-year younger self
when you were there at lloyd's
you know just getting your first house
what what would you say to yourself
honestly i'd say because i've been
meaning to do it for a long time but it
wasn't until i was made redundant until
i went full-time i don't think i would
have quit my job so what i'd say i think
procrastination is definitely the
biggest dream killer um i feel like a
lot of us um i feel because i'm a
christian i feel like god will give us a
purpose and i feel like it's our sort of
understanding to sort of execute this
purpose um what you find out a lot of
people do things that you want to do and
you wake up and you think oh no they
stole my idea now that they stole their
ideas just god gave everyone a plan and
they just managed to execute it first
yeah so apache i looked into is in the
book of solomon um god appeared to him
in a dream just asked him what do you
want i gave him a big piece of paper and
he just said you know what to give me
wisdom knowledge he could have asked for
anything rich is financing but he just
said give me um wisdom and knowledge
yeah so from that he was able to sort of
take over from his father david and sort
of rule the world so people when i when
i tell people i'm like if you need
anything it's not finance it's a problem
it's the wisdom and knowledge so just
get the training done
later yeah so if you get your training
done and the training course everywhere
there isn't free content online so don't
think finance is a barrier to entry
you're just telling yourself that you're
just procrastinating at the same time
yeah so just get the training and the
knowledge down once you get that sorted
everything else to follow because um
someone knew that once you had the
wisdom and the knowledge everything else
will follow as a ruler as a king he'd
get the finance the riches but he didn't
answer that straight away if you have he
gave god basically gave him a blank
check and he said you know what i want
wisdom and knowledge and god gave him
that and he was able that's so good
because it reminds me you know when
people win the lottery yeah they lose
the money yeah yeah because
they've been given the money or they've
won the money but they haven't got the
capacity to hold it to manage it to keep
it to invest it the number one thing is
knowledge and understanding and training
yeah that's with that you can go a long
way even if you don't have the money you
can find the money you can leverage the
knowledge and the training you have if
you have the money eventually and you
have no training have no understanding
of money management that could go and
you're left with nothing so if anything
what i talk to myself is make sure you
get the right training and the track and
the right knowledge because that will
never leave you and the thing is as well
if there's people watching this that are
like 18 19 years old you know
you don't necessarily have to do what
you did and go on advanced get a mentor
pay thousands you can just start reading
books
you know just start doing something just
what you focus on expands doesn't it and
what you track you see if you think how
many books i've read this month yeah you
know how many who am i hanging around
with what what am i watching on tv it
can just be small small steps to begin
with and then obviously you know like
you did if you get to the point where
you you're thinking no i want to do this
full time then fine invest invest a bit
more heavily but um
what what's your strongest reason then
what is it that gets you up in the
morning um it's that
i'm actually doing something i enjoy now
so um what's amazing is i can work
within my own schedule as well so i can
wake up whenever i need to have my own
meetings manage my own sort of business
at the same time and because something i
don't feel it doesn't feel like work i'm
actually enjoying it you actually wake
up you get to see these developments you
get to see this house you actually walk
through the whole process you see when
it's run down and you see when it's
renovated yeah then you see when it's
rented to the housing association and
what's good about this is because you
get these asylum seekers or these people
that are struggling and you're providing
them with a brand new house right
effectively that's just amazing because
you're essentially giving these people a
better place to live in yeah and i just
feel like that's just part of my purpose
to sort of help these people out put
them in a nice place to live basically
yeah so basically you love the process i
love the process yeah you love the
process i love the renovation of it it
doesn't feel like work yeah it doesn't
i'm getting paid a good amount
much more than when i was working at
lloyd's what does an average day look
like for you
average so wake up uh depends on sort of
area i'm in in terms of what i'm looking
for if i'm actively looking for
investments right now if i'm sort of
managing projects so first one have a
conversation with my builders understand
what's going on understand what needs to
be done understand because for this
housing association specifically as
targets that needs to be met in terms of
the houses need to be delivered and the
contract needs to stand over so it's
making sure the workers are doing what
they need to do at the same time
actively looking for investments at the
same time at the same time also trying
to raise finance at the same time so
yeah maybe going to my private investors
asking them potentially if they've you
know what's good about what you've done
though now wanting to do developments if
you find some development opportunities
which of course you will i bet you're
already finding out i do yeah i've been
on course speak to your button yeah okay
of course but the thing is it's going to
be easier for you to raise finance
because you've got a track record now
yeah you're making three to five grand a
month you've got a little portfolio
you've proven that you're you know
you're full-time in property you've
proven that you know how to manage money
manage investments so now trying to
partner with people on bigger deals
it's gonna be a dream definitely yeah
awesome final words of wisdom
final words of wisdom
i would say um
just go as hard as possible um if
property is really something you want to
do
go as hard as you want if it's something
you're 50 thinking about it it's not
going to work you need to 100 into it
you need to actually enjoy what you do
at the same time because it's not easy
there's times you'll get knocked back
but it's whether you're actually willing
to actually do this i mean there's other
things you can do you can do crypto if
you're lacking different things or
property is a different completely
different game you can lose a lot of
money and you can make a lot of money so
just make sure it's definitely what you
want to do and it's something that
you're going to enjoy because it's not a
short-term game i don't think you're
going to get rich overnight i think it's
a long time game then you've got put all
your time and all your effort you have
to honestly have to sort of enjoy what
you're doing yeah so that's what i
definitely tell people i appreciate that
brad thanks for coming down respect
[Music]